Is there any work going on here?
Uh, yeah.
We're looking up a hot
guy to see if he's single.
Slide over, Ainsley.
Kitchen's down there.
You better get here early
if you want a muffin.
A food that should never be
put in the microwave in an
office kitchen is spaghetti, honey.
Because it's going to splat all over the place.
If it lives under the sea,
you cannot microwave it in a communal office kitchen.
I know that this is a bold statement,
but if I wanna have tuna fish
at eight in the morning before my day starts,
that's what I need.
If I need to microwave a salmon
in order to fill myself up
and feel good and feel strong,
then let me have it, okay?
Fine, whatever.
Can I get back to catfishing
my ex's dad now?
I know we shouldn't be watching
this, but she is so compelling.
It is always okay
to purposely eavesdrop
on a coworker's love life.
Haha, she broke his heart.
Most people don't know how
to handle their own lives so
by you eavesdropping
on their conversation,
you're helping them by judging them.
Next.
And, another gay guy with a niece.
How original.
You didn't do any of the
work, your sister did.
Personal calls during work?
Should never happen.
Yo, if this is the guy
I sold my PS5 to,
the controllers were like
that when I bought it.
You got to take a call,
you gotta take it.
And you gon' to put it on speaker
and let everybody know.
If you're having an argument with your wife
that's affecting your work,
people should know that.
They shouldn't guess why you're
not having a good day at work.
They should've heard
your wife yelling at you.
Are you listening to me?
Hey baby, will you hold on for a second
there's some type of IT emergency.
What, someone hacked the database?
It's probably China again.
Look, I have to call you back, okay?
The bathroom is for poop and pee.
It's not for chat, okay?
So keep it to your off hours.
I don't think there's any safe topic
in the bathroom.
It is never okay to chit
chat in the work bathroom.
Unless, you're going to be in there
for longer than 10 minutes.
It's like being in a confessional.
You can't see each other's faces
and you can tell all your secrets.
This is completely inappropriate.
Have fun.
'Cause you worked hard.
Having some beers with my two compadres.
Okay weirdo, what's going on?
What's wrong with you?
Are you dying?
Limited to after work
and maybe one "brew-tava."
You never want to be
the drunkest person at the office.
So make sure you work
with a couple of alcoholics.
I had quite a bit of wine and....
Stop inviting me to the work
related happy hours.
I don't want to know
what your kid's names are.
I certainly don't want to know
what your pet's names are.
I really don't even want to
know what your name is.
I've learned a lot today.
The world is in a much, much worse place
than I thought it was and that's
a real bummer, but, I'm still pumped.